i just want to bring you some breaking
news coming
to us from the united states and the
television host larry king
has died at the age of 87 at the
cedars-sinai medical center
in los angeles there is a statement from
the company that
uh represented him on twitter or a media
and it reads for 63 years and across the
platforms of radio
television and digital media larry's
many
thousands of interviews awards and
global acclaim
stand as a testament to his unique and
lasting talent
as a broadcaster additionally while it
was his name appearing in the show's
titles
larry always viewed his interview
subjects as the true stars
of the programmes and himself as merely
an unbiased conduit between the guest
and
the audience whether he was interviewing
a u.s
president foreign leader celebrity
scandal ridden personage or an everyman
larry liked to ask short direct and
uncomplicated questions
he believed concise questions usually
provided
the best answers and he was not wrong in
that belief
larry's interviews from his 25-year run
on
cnn's larry king live and his aura media
programmes larry king now
and politicking with larry king are
consistently referenced
by media outlets around the world and
remain part of the historical record
of the late 20th and early 21st
centuries
aura media sends our condolences to his
surviving
children larry jr chance cannon
and the entire king family funeral
arrangements and a memorial service will
be announced later in coordination with
the king family
who ask for their privacy at this time
so larry king the television host has
died at the age of 87.
there's